هذه هي الشاحنة السوبر الكهربائية الجديدة كليًا من جي إم سي
، هامر إيف ، وهي جنونية تمامًا ،
فهي تحتوي على
نظام تعليق هوائي متكيف بأربع عجلات ، ودرع سفلي
، وثلاثة محركات كهربائية
لإنتاج 1000 حصان ،
نعم بقوة ألف حصان ،
لكن كل هذا العزم والتكنولوجيا
يتطلبان  الكثير من البطاريات وهذا
يعني شاحنة ثقيلة جدًا تبلغ
9000 رطل من الشاحنة في الواقع ، فإن
الشيء الأكثر إثارة للدهشة بالنسبة لي هو على الرغم من
حقيقة أن هامر إيف
يزن أكثر من هامر h1 الأصلي ،
إلا أنه لا يبدو هكذا  الطريق
لا تشعر وكأنك تقطر حوالي
تسعة آلاف رطل
[موسيقى]
ولكن هنا تكمن المشكلة في
أن سيارة هامر إيف سهلة القيادة
ولكن مع توجها الهائل
وعزم الدوران الكافي للانتقال من صفر إلى 60 في ثلاث
ثوانٍ ، دعنا  آمل أن
لا ينسى المالك العادي أبدًا أنه يقود الأطفال
لممارسة كرة القدم في
خزان يبلغ وزنه أربعة أطنان ونصف طن
، تم تصميم هامر الأصلي للاستخدام
الجاد على الطرق الوعرة ، لكنه اكتسب
سمعة طيبة بالنسبة للدكتور.  من
المحتمل أن يكون هذا الهامر أكثر
قدرة على الطرق الوعرة ولا يستخدم البنزين على
الإطلاق
بالإضافة إلى ميزاته الأخرى على الطرق الوعرة ، حيث
تتميز هذه الشاحنة بوضع فريد
للسير على شكل سرطان البحر ، كما أنها تحتوي على كاميرات في
الهيكل السفلي.  هامر حتى
مستكشف بلد خلفي قادر جدًا ،
فهذه شاحنة كبيرة ولكنها في
الواقع لا تقود بنفس الحجم الذي هو عليه جزئيًا
لأن ميزة التوجيه الرباعي
الفظيعة للغاية ولكن في هذا النوع من التضاريس
مفيدة جدًا
في الواقع  بيئة الطريق ، أعني
أن جودة الركوب جيدة بشكل مدهش ،
أعني أن هذا قريب جدًا من
سيارة السيدان الفاخرة كما ستحصل عليه في
مكان مثل هذا ،
لكن دعنا نوضح أن معظم
وحوش تسلق الصخور هذه
لن تبتعد كثيرًا  بعيدًا عن طريق الكهف
للقيادة اليومية ، فإن الركوب
مريح للغاية وهذا الشيء له
نصف قطر دوران لخنفساء فولكس فاجن ، والزجاج الأمامي
واسع للغاية وضيق يحتاج إلى ثلاث
مساحات للزجاج الأمامي ولكن الجزء الداخلي
مصمم جيدًا مع  من خلال واجهة مستخدم لطيفة للغاية ،
فإن الشاحنة الإضافية التي اختبرناها تحتوي على جميع
وسائل الراحة التي تتوقعها في
مركبة 100000 ،
فإن هامر إيف حقًا شاحنة رائعة جدًا
وقادرة على حجمها ، فهي تحصل على نطاق جيد
إن لم يكن فعالًا للغاية يبلغ حوالي 329
ميلًا  بتكلفة كاملة
ولكن من فضلك من أجل أي شخص آخر
على الطريق ، ضع في اعتبارك الكتلة التي بين
يديك